[Música]
Ya lo decíamos vamos a Venezuela porque
las protestas de trabajadores públicos
cumplen una semana iniciaron los
profesores pero ya se han Unido otros
sectores que piden un alza en los
salarios y una mejora en las condiciones
laborales aseguran que lo que ganan
actualmente no alcanza ni siquiera para
la canasta básica conectamos con Daniela
Zambrano corresponsal de France 24 en
Caracas Daniela Qué posibilidades reales
tienen estos trabajadores de ser
escuchados por el gobierno y de que sus
demandas se cumplan Cuáles son además
estas demandas
en esta oportunidad los trabajadores
públicos principalmente el gremio de
maestros pidió de un plazo hasta el
jueves para que las autoridades se
pronuncien y respondan a sus demandas o
de lo contrario continuarían las
protestas Cuáles son estas demandas ya
lo decían ustedes básicamente es la
homologación de los salarios a la
canasta básica para poner en contexto a
la audiencia en el mes de noviembre la
canasta básica según en la federación
venezolana de maestros se ubica en 474
dólares al mes de enero el salario
mínimo promedio no llega a los siete
dólares por eso es que estos
trabajadores han salido a protestar Ya
llevan una semana de manera consecutiva
pero realmente son protestas que llevan
meses y hasta años tanto el sector salud
como el transporte como los educadores
porque mientras no haya cambios en en
materia económica cambios estructurales
un simple aumento de salario no serviría
porque inmediatamente la
pulverizaría esos salarios en esta
oportunidad la manifestación en Caracas
iba a ser frente al Ministerio de
Educación sin embargo el gobierno cerco
los alrededores y los trabajadores
cambiaron el rumbo de esta manifestación
a una plaza a otra plaza en el centro de
Caracas pero realmente hubo protestas en
al menos diecinueve estados del país
porque estas exigencias como lo venía
diciendo son por parte de todos los
trabajadores públicos bueno y cambiando
un poco el tema Daniela el Ministerio
Público la fiscalía de Venezuela emitió
la tercera orden de captura contra el
opositor Julio Borges que está exiliado
en Colombia desde 2018 es posible que
sea extraditado tras el cambio de
gobierno en Colombia
esa fue una pregunta que se hicieron la
mayoría de opositores que se encontraban
en el exilio luego del cambio de
gobierno pero precisamente el propio
presidente colombiano a través de la red
social Twitter en esta oportunidad en el
mes de agosto respondió a una de las
peticiones de extradición que hicieron
funcionarios del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro entre ellos diosdado cabello
vicepresidente del partido de gobierno y
Gustavo Petro escribía textualmente eh
que Colombia garantiza El derecho de
asilo y Refugio lo que daba a entender
que estos opositores no serían
extraditados Esta es la tercera orden de
captura contra Julio Borges recordemos
que en primer lugar fue por
supuestamente estar implicado en un
intento de magnicidio contra maduro en
2018 en la segunda oportunidad se pidió
su detención por el conflicto del oro en
los bancos de Inglaterra que el gobierno
interino decía que se están protegiendo
los activos el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro que se está robando ese dinero y
en esta oportunidad fue por unas
recientes declaraciones del dirigente
opositor Leopoldo López quien decía que
Julio Borges había participado en ese
intento en este intentona de
levantamiento militar del pasado 30
abril de 2019 Julio Borges respondió a
través de las redes sociales dijeron que
decía que esto era un nuevo intento de
persecución pero que sin embargo no se
le intimidaba y que seguiría en la lucha
para que haya un cambio de gobierno en
Venezuela